you
[Music]
regarde Tysons chairman and CEO of
kaiser permanente welcome to stanford
into systems leadership thank you great
being here so tell me a little bit about
how you think about all the
constituencies in healthcare it's very
complex with doctors and nurses and
physicians and and new technology
development of the government how do you
think about how you need to balance all
of those various players that you need
to interact with as you run the business
well you know our model is all about
integration partnerships how it all
comes together we are unique in a lot of
ways and that's one of the ways in which
we were unique because we have total
responsibility if you will for the care
and coverage of the almost 13 million
people that were privileged to take care
of so I'm always thinking about it in
the context of how it comes together how
it integrates and how it enabled us to
do what we need to do providing the care
and the coverage to the populations that
we take care of how much of your time do
you spend dealing with internal
constituents and how much of your time
with external constituents that's a
great question you know it goes back and
forth but I would say probably about 45
55 you pick which side you want but
generally about 55 percent of the time
is internal and I'll say about 45
percent is outside and actually I'm
surprised by that because I assumed that
I would be spending a little bit more
time inside and then doing my stuff
outside as well and the outside
influences so much what happens inside
I've discovered in this role and so I
spend a lot of time with customers with
the government different environments
and it's extremely helpful in helping my
thought process for the issues and the
priorities that I'm taking on inside of
the organization spend a second talking
about the government's role in
healthcare and it was obviously been a
lot of discussion with the Affordable
Care Act and what's been happening since
how do you think about when you're
interacting with government how you take
your learnings and your interactions and
then convey those messages back inside
and how those interactions outside
influence how you take care of the
patients that come through Kaiser yeah
I think of the government a lot as
planned two major roles a very big
important customer that is covering the
lives of millions of Americans through
the ACA through Medicare through
Medicaid and other government-sponsored
programs and so I pay attention to what
my customer has to say it is also a big
regulator and in that relationship it's
a combination of making sure that they
understand and we have the proof of how
we are complying against a set of
regulations but it is also playing a
role of how to consult with the
government to help them to understand
the evolution of healthcare and that's
very important in Kaiser Permanente
because we invest so much in technology
that gives us a different kind of
infrastructure how we make sure that our
members are getting safe effective care
so let's talk about technology what are
the two or three ways that you think
digital influences are changing how
Kaiser delivers care to its customers in
its patients just the overall
communication is probably the one of the
biggest one members having access to our
delivery system in so many ways now you
could come in and visit us you can go to
a Target store in Southern California
and you're linked to the Kaiser
Permanente big in that kind of context
you can do secure a visit so you can
text and now at the Kaiser Permanente
you could set up video conferences to
interact directly with the physician so
it has allowed us to what we call
execute on our care anywhere strategy so
you not restricted to just coming in to
see the doctor anymore you can be on the
beach and send a message to your
physician that
need health care so it really has
dramatically changed how we think about
delivering health care I think the
another examples inside where we now
have through our technology an advanced
monitoring system for all of our
patients who are in our hospital beds in
Northern California and with the systems
and the AI technology now the it allows
us to go upstream and the seat of
potentials of someone happening or
potentially going into cold or something
like that and so the response team in
the past used to be for those cold blues
and they used to run and save a life now
they actually respond ahead of time to
go and check on a patient with the floor
nurses and others to make sure that the
patient is okay so a real critical issue
in digital healthcare is privacy and and
patients feeling comfortable that their
data is protected
how does Kaiser think about what you do
in ensuring that patients are protected
and that data is protected we think
about it all the time in two levels of
that one is the privacy to make sure
that no one is going into the health
record who is not authorized and/or who
should not be in the health record and
so we have all kinds of features around
that and the ability to what we call the
fingerprint the ability to track who
went into the records the second one is
how to keep bad people out cyber
security and all the work that we do
there we actually have a cybersecurity
committee at Kaiser Permanente and I
chair it that's how important it is to
the organization as you can imagine no
one likes to have any of your personal
information compromised there's a big
difference in how people feel about your
credit card being compromised versus
your personal health record so the
stakes are high and how do we keep that
information as confidential as possible
so you chair that committee and if you
think back you've been with a company I
believe 33 years 35 35 years now ok and
you've been the CEO for six years what's
the biggest surprise to you that you
didn't expect about the
the CEO that you've learned since you
took over the position that it's very
much an enjoyable job but it is a 24/7
job and you don't turn it off
because there's so much going on you
know exciting things and challenging
things and you feel the responsibility
obviously directly and so it it is
consuming but it's a good kind of
consumption Bernard Tyson CEO Kaiser
Permanente thank you so much for coming
back to Stanford's always a pleasure to
have you here it's great to be here
[Music]